Elijah hello Elijah yeah what's going on
yes okay hold on the seer of course I
have been for we're all on Sam Barnett
hi Sam how are you right now yeah but
let's talking on the air okay
she's with BBC okay season two premieres
October 14th on BBC America hope you
guys aren't doing Fallon later so you
were not internal affairs
do you hang out with Richard Gere or
anything hanging out with Richard Gere
but yeah I was around him here's why man
he was practicing that question he lost
weight the eye I have thank you I feel
like I put a couple back on but I've
kind of kept most of it off looking good
dude Thank You Man the reason I asked is
we just have Michael Madsen do a stellar
interview in here he was awesome Wow I
had Madsen yes sitting on a budget he
was [ __ ] on Kevin Costner everyone
Clooney
oh yeah and then he asserted that all
men beat their girlfriends is an
interview for the agent yeah yeah and
podcasted can people it just happened
yeah Wow like he looked I was talking
about the NFL and I said yeah but
haven't they lost a little bit of honor
with the you know with the with the wife
beaters and the dog beaters and stuff
and he was like you have a girlfriend I
was again I have a wife and he was like
you ever smack her and I said why what
no and he was like I don't believe it
and he's usually and that's saying that
he's implicated himself in beating his
former girlfriend no he just no Sam hits
his for everyone it was just me but I
had this open so I asked Michael I'm
like you were in internal affairs I got
in recognize him from internal affairs
internal affairs know that's the but
mount was his reaction knowledge
internal and then it turns out it was
your he was reading your [ __ ] IMDB I
had open to the bottom in 1990 I mean I
didn't realize how will you know you
were in internal affairs
I was mmm yeah it was I was 1990 so we I
think we shot in 89 I was I was eight
what did you do in it I play
ball which Baldwin is in that film why I
don't remember it's been since I've seen
I played the son of one of the
characters Wow okay I didn't realize
that so I thought Madsen maybe played
like a cop or something
so I asked him and was correct corrected
I think I'm only in like two or three
scenes
do you remember auditioning for it I
don't remember auditioning I remember
working on it and then the two people
who played my parents took me to the zoo
so that they could get a sense of like
we could have a form somewhat of a bond
before we started filming as their sons
not wait that's really sweet
yeah I think that sounds like a nice
I've ever liked your parent though I'd
be like we're trying to get in character
and I don't yeah he's our son because I
I've gotten many times I've talked about
Daniel day-lewis and there will be blood
the way he touched the kid and that like
have you worked with a kid where you had
to like hug him or pick him up yes no I
don't if he touches no he touches
meeting when you work with a kid who's
not your kid yeah it seems like a really
scary feeling you have to touch him as
if you're their parent yes in the film
in the role right and I've never played
a parent because he he the way he
handled his son in that right I was like
he's touching someone else's kid but
support and it really looked like it was
his son I'm like that level of comfort
right I see where it's just so taken the
you to the zoo is not that crazy no not
that crazy I just bring it all back
around for no reason spoil the
interviewer who gives a [ __ ] about a guy
that retired from acting abruptly you
know why he retired by the way anyone no
idea they lose left no I don't I think
if I were to see circa I guess I think
it's he goes through a very intensive
process that everyone knows about you
know it's sort of legendary that he goes
so far into becoming his character that
he lives us that character for the
duration of the film you know on Lincoln
he was only referred to as Abraham
Lincoln on set on the crucible he helped
build the sets of the town and also
lived in one of
homes so I think you can imagine an
extrapolate on that that that would be a
very intensive thing to do every time
you go to make a film where he literally
extracts himself from regular life for
that period of time and I think that's a
lot so his wife is like I'm tired of
[ __ ] Abe Lincoln like it's not as we
turn off like when they say cut we're
often we're talking amongst ourselves
when we go back in and it's it's not one
versus the other in regards to how you
get there I think his performances are
extraordinary but I also think that
takes a toll must be tiring have you
guys had to work with people that don't
turn off like the way he doesn't turn
off because I always wonder if that's
annoying with other people right to the
other actors we had an actress on our
season that didn't come off yeah we did
really yeah we did what did she do
there's a character in our show can we
say yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
actresses is really wonderful and super
charming and she kind of her thing is to
sort of be in the character the entire
time Wow and what anyway that's not
annoying for you to be like let's have a
conversation wasn't annoying she's not
annoying that's a question she's lovely
yes oh well that is true but characters
a really beautiful character in there
and in a way I mean if anyone's gonna
stay in character it's it's great that
it's her because it's one of the
weirdest characters in the entire show
so much difference in her as a person
that is a good point I actually don't
know no I don't kiss cuz I genuinely
don't know what she's so she seems very
sweet but I don't care achter de be
around yeah so the fact that that was
the person you were around wasn't
annoying because yes in my nature I
think it would depend on the person
right yeah I would be embarrassed to
stay in character like cut and then that
sound guy is doing something I'm feeling
like I'm being an imposition on the
entire crew to support my thing but but
right but saying that I don't have I
have full respect for people who do it
yeah I mean I would feel embarrassed but
it's not to say that the person doing it
is wrong because you just I don't think
I have the capacity to do that because
it would feel like I'm drawing too much
attention to myself right you don't want
your your the people who are working
with you on these projects to all be
living under this assumption that this
is an elijah project and it's all about
you and we're just here to make sure
that we get the best performance out of
elijah like you're like no we're a team
you're a team yeah and that's how I
think but again it's no criticism to the
people that do it because my god the
results are amazing and you know it's a
it's a it's a sandbox right and
everybody's doing their specific role to
contribute and if that one person needs
a certain environment to exist in that
space fair enough I sit in the sandbox
and the cat covers me who then continues
to portray the character poorly off in
the end anyway I would imagine like in
community theater or something there are
people who take themselves way too
seriously the just stink at it and and
are doing that and are like they read
the Daniel day-lewis does it so right
like well I'm also a great actor so I'm
gonna do this and you have to just deal
with them doing like a terrible accent
you don't know that happens yeah of
course it you know what I haven't cooked
encountered more often than not though
is not method but rather people keeping
their accent going that I've seen that's
why it makes me laugh but just to help
themselves yeah so it's more natural so
you know Fergana um fiona d'oeuvres
father brad dourif
he was in Lord of the Rings and whose
nest yeah God and the Exorcist 3 oh my
god he's so good in a tremendous voice
in which he was in Coretta
and he was also dead wood as well he's
by the way his daughter is also in the
new Chucky movies and yes she is also in
our show Hey he plays Bart yeah did you
meet right yeah I worked with Brad a bum
oh you mean the Lord of the Rings man
sir yeah but the thing about Brad on
taking it back to that thing on Lord of
the Rings he kept his accent going the
whole time just because it helped him
with you know a foreign thing that he
wasn't used to you didn't read but you
were speaking totally having
conversations with Brad he was not warm
tough fionna does not she keeps that she
keeps the bat voice but you're very much
talking to Fiona do you think he did
that in Cuckoo's Nest we had to keep a
stutter because he had a bad stutter and
that I'm like you do that off with
camera when you're we imagine he may
have yeah that wouldn't annoy me as much
as somebody pretending they were a
totally different part but then you have
such a lack of being self-conscious
that's probably why Danny Dale is so
[ __ ] great because he has no fear of
embarrassing himself no self-conscious
he's just this guy and to be able to do
that in real life is probably been
harder to do that offset than it is on
so you can pull it off offset it it's
sort of a thing you could look the fool
right so it's actually great I mean I
just I just want to check my phone
between scenes I don't want to keep work
yeah
downtime yeah you're gonna rest quite
lazy how does a guy you're playing from
who you are though like are you playing
okay it's very different I think I think
I think he's totally different and then
throughout season one and season two
people he going my coaches so like Dirk
so I I don't know I think he's totally
different I I think some people think
that I often think that you are the
characters that you play and I'm really
not I can speak as fast as he speaks
because otherwise I couldn't speak as
opposed to see speaks do you know what I
mean but there right kind of it that's
funny though because people get so used
to the TV show they're like oh that's
you and you're like yeah did you know me
at all before the TV you guys playing
this can you describe the show a little
bit for anybody who's not seen it go
yota alright the show Dirk gently's
holistic detective agency is a show
about Dirk Gently who is a holistic
detective a holistic detective is
someone who instead of using clothes and
the sort of
the regular step-by-step process of
determining how to solve a case allows
the universe to show him where he needs
to go it puts the things in front of him
which seemingly are tangential and
random and chaotic and those things
ultimately hopefully will lead to a
result that solves the case and it's
essentially about Dirk and my character
Todd who he's got roped in to be his
assistant unwillingly and then sort of
now is a willing participant kind of
navigating these cases and each season
is a case it's was described by max this
season to us that it's actually an
anthology show in the sense that each
season is a different story but it's
also a different set of genre so our
first season was time travel and body
swapping and this season is high fantasy
and magic but it's the same character so
it's an anthology show in which the same
characters occupy the show but it
explores different cases in different
worlds is there any type of thing that
actually works like this is this a
totally fictional style of being a
detective or no with that is this a
totally fictionalized style of being a
detective or is there anything called
holistic never been tried by anybody or
no I just don't think that's a thing I
think partly because it is dark very
much relying on his intuition right but
it's also a bit of a really crappy
superpower that he has right it's crappy
as in because it it doesn't really work
very well
and he gets into a mess all the time but
essentially he is sort of connected to
some sort of energy and flow of the
universe which really does take him
where he needs to end up well intuition
is something I mean look you get
solutely it's scientifically provable no
it's not but sometimes you just know
like you ever someone gets on the
elevator and you're like oh that's
person to creep and you just know to do
radio with them yeah absolutely
[Laughter]
so max landis is obviously the creator
and the writer and everything in the
show and I think we talked about him a
little bit when you came in last year to
promote season one that it was such like
a like this show is so different from
any
else it's on TV when it is successful
especially successful enough to get a
season 2 hmm dis max then kind of go
nuts with his season 2 and realize well
now I don't have to the little bit that
I didn't improve two people to get
season 1 on the air now that it's a
success I can do whatever I want is
there that feeling or do not either I
think what's great about BBC America is
is the risk that they took on doing this
show because I think max from the
beginning has done what he thinks I need
to do and what's right for him so if
anything this is just gonna confirm that
it was a great idea and and he now is
going to run with it yeah and and
honestly before we even got a season 2
he had it mapped out already well he
said the first four seasons there yes in
his mind that's gonna be great for you
guys cuz you know you're probably gonna
get two more seasons at work or at least
if you do get the seasons it's not gonna
be some guy frantically like oh my god I
got to write another season just like
that's true that's very much a plan I
think totally and the great thing about
the second season is that the
establishing is out of the way right the
notion of like what are we doing tonally
who are these characters where are they
coming from that work is done
essentially so it's now just expounding
on those characters journeys and it it
allows the freedom of just like jumping
into a story which just yeah there's
there's also a complicated aspect to the
storytelling that existed in the first
season that certainly is a part of the
season it's very chaotic things
seemingly are disconnected so it sort of
requires you to focus to follow it sure
the first season was far more
complicated like willfully complicated I
wasn't told like it was sort of on
purpose that complicated that as an
audience you have to sit back let it
wash over you and you do get the answers
and the end result you have to wait a
few episodes I thinks it's almost like
training you it watch the show like it
is yes because it's so unique right I
think we had to teach people how to
watch it um season two I think is a lot
more streamlined it's set in three very
specific places they all feed into the
same mystery it's I think it's easier to
follow but no less complicated no less
crazy and I think a lot more fun and
character-driven because we know our
characters so well now and it's also
just to give you what it's gonna
premiere
the 14th on BBC America yes how did you
find BBC Americans I don't know he's
know where everything is on a kid I use
sometimes Google helps like I'll just
google it FiOS maybe see America you
Google could help every single time BBC
America comm yeah you can catch season 1
on Hulu oh yeah and then season 2 yeah
on BBC America do you get nervous when a
show premieres and people aren't gonna
like it yeah yeah I think last season in
particular because it was is such a bold
show there really isn't anything quite
like it so I think the anticipation of
people getting what we were trying to do
and and going along with it was a little
bit more of a fear this season less so I
feel like that's what's gonna ask me now
and maybe haven't even thought of this
and I'm just putting the pressure into
your head for the first time now like
the new pressure is okay because there's
there's a legitimate cult fan base for
this show now in America now you have to
live up to expectations before it was
like let me show you this thing let me
get you on board now you're going into
season two with like expectations are
established and it has to live up to it
I agree but I I mean maybe I would say
this because I'm in it but I also feel
like a fan of it because it's so crazy
and it's so wide-ranging that I can't
hold the whole thing in my head so I do
feel a bit objective about it and I
think this season defies those
expectations it certainly did for me
when I was reading the scripts it's like
this is even better than season one yeah
I mean we can't say how people are going
to react sure there's that unknowable
thing but I with a similar amount of
objectivity
I prefer where this season goes and I
think it it improves upon the first
season so yeah I don't have a great deal
of apprehension no creatively I'm really
proud of it and yes I did I'm excited to
people to say it feels like a show that
now knows what it is
right and Sam we didn't know you were
coming we didn't you I don't have your
your your bio in front of me I'm happy
you're here but what did you do right
before before this I was doing penny
dreadful oh you do
yes series done I use it it's done yeah
they
finished it very very quickly at the end
of season three it kind of it wrapped up
and suddenly it was over and I think the
fans were really kind of disappointed
because it was exciting did you know it
was going away no I had no idea we we
weren't told it was very much between
that niche you were probably in this
like space of like you know what it
worked out really well because I was
optioned for another couple of seasons
on Penny dreadful and had that gone on I
would not have been able to do this and
I actually I was cheating a little I was
flying on the plane to my screen test
whilst not knowing if I had even be able
to do it because penny dreadful was
still at that point going her did you
suspect that my god was that close oh it
was really close yeah we were kind of
like okay let's just not tell you I mean
it's bad but we're like let's just not
tell anyone here well just carry on with
this process and see how it works out
and thank god it did you were just they
literally just blindsided you and said
alright we're done
there's no indication no they did to
everyone fans fans and cast to like I
mean not in a bad way it had a very
satisfying ending as a show I just think
people felt it had more in it that could
have run with it but of course um Ava
Green's character got killed off and I
feel like she was the linchpin in that
show right so without her it was a
question of can you reinvent in
hindsight it's kind of nice sometimes
when a show that you like ends before
like things like the office yeah in the
UK two seasons right same with like
Fawlty Towers great comedies that
Britain sometimes doesn't they do two
seasons and it's enough in America that
that that fruit was squeezed very true
they they tend to milk things here and
they did more pressure I guess cuz
there's 24 episodes to see it you know
Ricky did six six a special invention
yeah anything with extras I think the
British you're better at doing that I
think they're better at doing that than
American shows all we're just like
leaving you wanting a little bit more I
think we're coming around to it though
this this notion of a limited series is
starting to pop up here which I love it
primarily exists on cable the network's
want to know something until it dies
right as if it's successful they're
making a [ __ ] ton of money and keep the
thing on the air as long as possible but
not
successful is the scariest thing in the
world whereas on streaming yeah never or
whatever or or or a cable channel
they're like okay well we got this other
series then yeah we'll just try it with
this one absolutely and I I just love
the freedom of something that's limited
it exists within one context and it
tells a story and however long it needs
to tell that story it doesn't yeah I
loved big little lies and the Oh a like
they were contained stories like I did a
limited series on it was it supposed to
be a limited series but it turned out to
be a yesterday I do I've done a lot of
well it's called lucky Louie was just a
whole character arc in one season and
also a couple of these just one offs
well Louis CK's HBO show the first one
yeah yeah it's so funny it was you know
it so funny I am I didn't see it at the
time and I remember it was so chided
like it was really really poorly
received by their critics yeah it was
you know cancelled immediately and then
I went back years later like once the
HBO go became a thing you kind of go
through the archives and check out stuff
it's really kind of clever and ahead of
its time I think it's really essentially
made you know an adult language like Odd
Couple II you know a live audience
studio audience with you know can sort
of multicam sitcom but with the content
that you would never have in a multi cam
sitcom I thought it was really I lent
the fans of that show were weird like we
we went up every week with with with
viewers it was weird but the critics
hated it and it's so funny to see them
love Louis so much now because the same
ones where's like he stinks they trashed
him for directing Pootie Tang
yeah now those same guys like oh okay we
got a genius yeah he's a brilliant cop I
guess that's how it is when they like
something they like it Elijah is uh his
nick from The Bachelor your favorite
celebrity friend cuz I feel like he'd be
my favorite celebrity friend if he was
my celebrity friend he's a nice guy
yeah I mean that's amazing I did you
watch The Bachelor ever I only watched I
only watched this last season yeah
because of him right I met him through
my friend Kyle who became friends with
him they met at a at a music festival
and became friends and so he was just in
in around and I became friendly with
with Nick and then he got in that
interim of knowing this guy he gets to
be the bachelor and we were like this is
so crazy and so getting a kind of look
into that world like he was sequestered
up into Bachelor land for months and
nobody could communicate with him and
then we all kind of watched the thing
unfold on TV despite the fact that he
knew what the result was essentially
right you know I mean cuz it's all pre
filmed a right course of a couple of
months sure of course yeah fascinating
yeah completely fascinating yeah and I
don't know that I'll ever watch the show
again it was really interesting what you
expected it to be or no yeah it's weird
it's uncomfortable to watch that show
fine what the and it's the same probably
for Bachelorette though I haven't seen
it but you know women or men fawning
over someone they don't know one person
- exactly with the intent the intent of
marrying that person is so strange to me
right with after two dates or which is
the equivalent of like 20 minutes here
and 15 minutes here and a dinner there
they're ready like we had a connection
those are nice dates fascinating getting
to know Nick was the the understanding
that that environment is so heightened
that it completely manipulates one's own
emotional feelings and thought processes
because it's it's you're in a bubble
right it's a complete microcosm so the
normal rules don't apply the normal time
it doesn't apply so a lot of these
people do believe and think that they
have a connection with someone that they
don't have because you'll see ladies
they get Houston a to get out of the
limo they meet this complete stranger
they say hello and after a Hello
there will be girls talking to the
camera that go like yeah I mean it was
really quick but I think we connected
and who knows maybe we'll be engaged by
the end of this thing you're like you
said hi okay you need you need to watch
unreal because okay yeah I've seen you
know I've seen what the first episode
right and I guess it was made if you
seen unreal it's unreal I have not it's
all that
Wow it's behind it set like behind the
scenes of a show like The Bachelor and
it's all about the producers and the
execs
who are behind the scenes manipulating
all of the contestants so it's like it's
it's a dramatized show cryptid shows it
based on reality or they just as a
people that created it yeah came from
that world yeah like we're showing away
where they're showing you the underbelly
of how a lot of this stuff is done yeah
they sent a brilliant show and it's the
kind of thing that a friend of mine told
me to watch and I was like I'm gonna
hate this I've never seen The Bachelor I
wouldn't watch this kind of TV it is
addictive
there had been two seasons already
there's another to comedy there's a lot
of humor in it a lot of humor but it's
dark it's dark ah how they manipulate
the contestants and and you realize how
you get people going we connected after
he looked at me once well as you're
watching because you know Nick you're
watching The Bachelor do you find
yourself like falling into this world be
like no that girl's not right for him
that girl's right for him oh you can't
help it so we're watching it why is he
keeping current around so much Callie
doesn't have his best interests at heart
totally and and despite the fact that
you have an understanding of the inner
workings of this thing right and how
heightened and slightly unrealistic the
whole kind of show business for your
entire life
like you do start to kind of go well
that girl is ridiculous but that person
is perfect for her of course you get
roped in what are you rooting for it to
be good though like nobody wants to see
it work like a train wreck is much more
interesting to watch then like how was
your date oh he was a delight you like
wolf but if it was a nightmare you want
to hear about it so we'd rather watch it
fall one was on the show for so long
right and that became apparent
immediately as soon as she had done a
few things that were like obviously you
kick her off now yeah and she stayed
like us gold dust for producers right
absolutely got that and I would and I'd
watch every week going and currently
very sweet by the way is she
yeah I've not met her but she did not
she doesn't come across this please
she didn't come right sure yeah she's
probably putting on a show to write she
knows her role a little bit all of them
are to a certain degree I think it's a
mix of people trying to put their best
foot forward as to who they
but also its weights against
entertainment yeah did you see your
friend on that show or did you feel like
he was playing a character I will give
him the utmost credit and say that I saw
Nick he's a genuine above human people
see Sam when they watch dirt the
woodsman he said people see Sam I was
implying that he's a pedophile his
lifestyle I don't beat my wife or my dog
or touch children or do you watch
reality show people who like they do
something like that and they have this
cat trying to bring it back you know
that's a really sad demise reality show
people and they say there's nothing left
for them the thing man like you you you
jump on that ship you're not to my
knowledge a lot of those people aren't
paid a great deal and then it's a
machine right and they want to keep you
in that machine and there's a million
different things that you can do that
kind of keep the lifestyle going and to
a certain degree financially I kind of
get it like if you came from nowhere and
then jumped into something suddenly
you're on TV your life kind of becomes
defined by that thing I was it's
difficult was that his third like
bachelor type show so in the franchise
and on The Bachelorette twice I think
and then he was on The Bachelor and then
he'll before that he did the bachelor in
paradise the fact that I know this much
about it yeah is very disturbing but
what is the where like if you're that
like you the go like okay I want to get
into a quarter quote legitimate keep it
going or do you just want to keep going
in that world it you'd have to ask each
individual person some people wanted to
stay in that world I think you get fame
like a lot of people get Fame and they
don't let them oh my god how do I keep
it died I like adulation how do I keep
it happening keep looking at me I need
another platform yeah whatever it is or
its income right I mean or for some of
them it's Inc are you both private guys
though like would you would you ever
consider doing something like that like
letting
hammers follow you around or do you
really love your privacy no I never one
that I love my privacy yeah that would
be a nightmare to me yeah have you have
you felt it invaded
I never but I mean have you ever I mean
I because I walk down the street with
you in Vancouver and like you get people
coming to you all the time for pictures
and things you're all always incredibly
gracious a number with them and very
kind but like has it ever been more like
invasive than that not really it's good
because I would think at some level
because you're like super recognizable
just from all the years and people you
know at a because you you hit you've hit
people at different points in their
lives based on whatever project like of
yours that they love and I would think
that that is just as bad as having a
camera following you around is that
knowing that kind of everywhere you go
people are like yeah there he is there
he is there he is it's yeah it's funny
man I I genuinely don't think about it
like I leave my house every day without
that being a consideration I'm just kind
of ghost about it's not well I suppose
but it's still all so weird to me right
even though I'm used to the fact that
people can recognize me and will come up
to me I do still find it a bit funny and
a bit weird and but it's genuinely not a
consideration I don't change the course
of my day to avoid contact with people
which is and that you've you've made it
you've normalized it in a good way yeah
yeah do you spend a lot of time doing
Hollywood celebrity things like a lot of
people immerse themselves in that world
they only interact with other famous
people and then there's people who are
like I just kind of avoided I think
that's part of why part of a myriad of
reasons why my life feels normal is I
don't I don't I my life exists outside
of I mean look for better or worse it's
not not to derive anybody wants to hang
out with other people in the industry
because that makes sense to like you you
know you work in the industry your
friends and people in the industry makes
total sense I just have always had
friends that were outside it or did
different things within the context of
of the world that we work in like be
that bash that make like that just make
my life richer and different and
slightly
there's an escape from it's important to
have a life outside of this in just 100
and some people don't and if their sense
of self depends on the industry then
they're screwed because the industry's
gonna go up and down up and down for
them I think you got to have a life yep